so my next uh loan to attack is my truck
loan okay and it's my only thing I have
left but it's a high one it's
around $83,000 left whoa it used to be
94 cuz how much is your payment it's
about 1,700 a month who Lord I mean
Kevin I I'm not going to sit here and
like convince you you're you're a grown
man you can do what you want but but our
biggest goal is that we want your money
working for you not against you there
are so much of your income and hard you
you make incredible money I mean 150 to
160 a year that actually be Building
Wealth for your family you could
actually be changing your legacy and
building your wealth with this versus
sending it to uh where Ford Motor
Company or wherever it is going